we can make china a peaceful country
have you ever said no
to beijing yes for many times i'm
telling you the fact
why don't you listen politicians in
taiwan
have been out campaigning in
presidential primaries ahead of next
year's election
with the topic of relations with china
very much on the agenda
my guest this week outside the capital
taipei
is choshi wei who's been seeking the
nomination of his
pro-beijing party the kuomintang as
china pushes with increasing
urgency for reunification and the
taiwanese continue to reject it
what on earth has his party got to offer
[Music]
joshy way welcome to conflict zone thank
you very much for inviting me
you said the only way to resolve
antagonism between china and to taiwan
is to talk and to love yes
what do you love about china that is
threatening taiwan both
verbally and militarily and holding a
sword over your head
continually how do you love that well
that's your impression actually if you
talk
to some chinese in mainland china as
long as
you don't support separation from china
they will not treat you like that
they'll not attack you
also don't say the the wrong thing
otherwise china will right
right and you can normalize that you
think that's a normal way to live
that a power across 180 kilometers of
the strait says to you
if you say the wrong thing you're
finished
well i don't think i don't think it's
that serious you haven't
keep saying i think you have to talk to
each other if you try to
visit china so-called china we called
mainland
okay we are taiwan they are mainland
we together it's a china it's one china
well if you think the threats from china
is so serious to taiwan why do you
european people
all the people around the world all the
members of in the u.n
try to work with china try to have
dialogue with china
try to solve problems it's traded you
know that as well as right
it's not a human rights record is there
we can destroy it and we can do that too
apart from trade what exactly does
democratic taiwan
have in common these days with one party
communist china you have free elections
yes you can change
you have independent courts they don't
you have a free press they don't
you can speak out against abuses of
power and they can't
what on earth have you got in common
with mainland china these days
uh i think we should emphasize the
differences
go there work with them be their friends
be their brothers
and change them instead of being their
enemies
go there work with them you can change
them
like what you are doing with them now do
you concern about human rights what on
earth is the evidence that you can
change them what on earth is the
evidence
well you see the trade surplus china
with mainland rights you see a lot of
changes in hong kong
recently why china is
not using force to press down the
demonstration
why they compromise why
because they seek opportunity to prove
they can change they can improve we'll
come on to hong kong a little later i
want to go into
some some detail on that but the serious
issue
is the military pressure from china
isn't it even two years ago
your government's national defense
report highlighted concerns that chinese
military activity
near taiwan posed an enormous threat to
security
in the taiwan states now just a few days
ago you had washington
saying that china has stepped up its
pressure campaign seeing the largest
increase in military activity around
taiwan for 20 years
and you think that's meaningless why usa
china is going to interfere the election
in taiwan
so u.s is coming here to interfere
taiwan's election
you're happy with these bullying taxes
because that's what they are not i'm not
happy
about bullying thing but that's what the
child is doing
i'm happy about you know we can do
business with each other
we can ask china to make changes we are
the
only people on earth believe that we can
make that happen
we can make china a peaceful country
when you look back the history
who's who are the invaders who are the
invaders
japan right who participate the wars
in asia you want to live in history or
you want to live in the beginning no i
want you to live in the person
i want to make history clear
that who are the invaders okay if you
want to be
someone's enemy then they will be your
enemy if you want to be someone's
friend oh if you're like you can see
that if only like okay
let me tell you one one thing why u.s is
selling f-16 to taiwan instead of f-35
and u.s is selling f-35 to korea to
japan
to singapore to other countries why
the united states gave the
diary island to ai to japan instead of
taiwan
it was our territory why the u.s is
doing that
to taiwan mr cho candy chen vice
president of the taiwan foundation for
democracy said last month that
more and more taiwanese feel their
nation is now
under existential threat and you seem to
be out of touch with that feeling
totally don't you
you don't feel undirected i feel the
reality i feel the reality
i know how to deal with the chinese in
mainland
i know what's the facts i know you
haven't had to deal with them you
haven't had to deal with them as a
politician i
try to deal with them when i was the
mayor here the
the biggest city mayor i worked with
the the city in nineteen i tried to
communicate with them
i tried to work with with them try to
ameliorate
carbon emission issues environmental
issues
education issues will work with them
what about the diplomatic front where
they continue to squeeze you where they
ramp up the pressure
where they try and persuade countries to
drop their recognition diplomatic
recognition
you did that you're not changing awesome
china didn't that remember this
you lost in 2018 thanks to chinese
russia you're now down in the second
team thank you
you recognize china you don't recognize
the
the republic of china you recognize that
you're talking about republicans china
is taiwan
we were the representative of china
before 1971 and the u.n
i took you and you go back to history
and say the prc
no i'm telling you the fact we exist
here the
the ro6 is here and that's what you call
the taiwan
but you never recognize the roc here you
recognize the prc
right well in the eu i read an article
recently we are here to one china policy
as regards to taiwan and hong kong and
i i think it should be defined like this
we we are here to one china policy
as regards to mainland taiwan
hong kong and macau mr cho you're not
talking about china that continues
efforts to thwart
taiwan's participation in international
organizations
like the world health organization and
interpol for instance you want to be
members of those organizations
china and china only you can help us is
trying
to stop it why you agree to that
why do you never criticize i'm scared
are you scared
of everybody i'm criticizing everyone no
no even china too
i didn't say that we've read a lot i
haven't have time
to express my opinion about china's
stuff this is wrong no this is hotel i
have to say one more thing
the u.n the eu
even germany you recognize the prc
you don't recognize the roc and i truly
hope one day
you recognize the roc you help us to
participate
wh o
that kenji tried to talk to man and they
tried to
try yeah they tried to do let us
participate
especially ho and icao
mr cho beijing is clearly losing
patience with taiwan while you dream of
some
vague love in between taipei and
and the mainland china is crystal clear
what it wants from you
and that's reunification and it refuses
to rule out
the use of force to get it doesn't it
and you live with that
and you normalize that on a daily basis
okay
in our country instead of saying to them
no
you can't see constitution okay
there's only one china policy and that
includes mainland taiwan hong kong and
macau
that's in our constitution we should
abide by all countries
constitutional rights you're being told
by xi jinping as you were in january
unification is an inevitable requirement
for the great rejuvenation of the
chinese people he said
taiwan should accept that it must and
will be reunited with china whatever
talks you've been having
with china hasn't got them out of that
idea and how many people
in taiwan want that reunification under
three percent
don't worry about that don't worry about
what the people think about you don't
worry about worrying about people
think but don't worry about their
threatening words why don't you stand up
to those threatening words well
we stand up too you won't we stand up to
that
but taiwan
have you tried to take a look of our
constitution
have you tried to take a look of our
laws mr
china and in our constitution
we want a peaceful relationship we want
a unification
the people is true the people don't
that's in our law and the constitution
people don't trust it it doesn't matter
what they
do then try to amend the constitution
that's your perception our people here
want to have a peaceful relationship
with mainland and we want to make money
we want to do business together we want
to have a democracy in the future in
mainland china
but not fighting extent against them not
taking them
as an enemy trying to be their friends
and
try to change them by participation like
what you do
that's why you wrote that's working so
well isn't it the reality is
mr cho that beijing's push on
unification
puts your party the kuomintang into a
very difficult position doesn't it
your veteran china expert su chi
actually said that he said
xi jinping took away all the space for
ambiguity
and that puts us the kuomintang in a
very
difficult situation that difficulty
being that your party is being told
get on with this by china and you don't
have a policy of standing up to it do
you
i do have a policy what is it i declare
that
i claim that i want to unify
china i want to unify under taiwan's
mainland
some chance 23 million
you have to understand history in the
world what's happening now unification
separation yes
yes that's the process unification
separation separation unification
that's the track of the history but
there's one thing very important
want unification have you ever stood up
to china
i stand up have you ever said no to them
i stand up
for the republic of china have you ever
said no to beijing
yes for many times what on human rights
issues
yes really
whenever i went to china i told them you
need to
introduce democracy to your society oh
they're listening
so we see the first the biggest
crackdown in 25 years taking place
on human rights activists human rights
watch reported last year
human rights defenders continue to
endure arbitrary detention
imprisonment and enforced disappearance
yes and you say nothing about that
have you heard i said anything about
that
i did just now i even told them i even
told them
because you don't know my history
dealing with them i have
many dialogues with them i tell them you
have to improve
that's human rights that's international
standards of treating your people
i told them too okay i have to tell you
one thing
if you don't participate if you don't
join them
if you don't treat them like they can
improve
then nothing good is going to happen
here it's a fine line between that and
appeasement isn't it
yes it's a very fast very fine line it's
very ambiguous
but you have to do that from your heart
people know that ever spoken up for the
tiny taiwanese democracy activist lee
ming-che it's more than
more than two years since he was
forcibly disappeared you haven't heard
of him
li min it's more than two years since he
was
forcibly disappeared by police in
china's guangdong province
and charged with subversion of state
power
he's a citizen of taiwan you don't talk
about you don't even know his name
no he's in terrible conditions human
rights groups around the world
have been campaigning for his release no
what about a governor he sent us to five
years in jail
can't get phone calls can't get letters
four times his wife was prevented from
from going to mainland china to visit
him
and you know his rights are being around
20 years ago
i tried to talk to
chinese communists to release and
espionage
suspects a lady who just got married
and it was released recently
i talked to our government too when cam
coming down was the ruling party and
they didn't step in
they didn't try to rescue her she was
sentenced to death
however in jail for 20 years just
a year ago she was released probably
just
in this year she was released
and look what the people here
have done to help human rights
you know we should try to work together
and we should try to talk to them
and what the government here do
let's talk about hong kong again you
mentioned it earlier in the interview
and you were you were praising china
that they had shown restraint
with the demonstration i'm not praising
them for that
who started this in the first place okay
that's the law
right for what the demonstrators will
tell you that it was the constant
erosion of their freedoms under the one
country two systems formula
that forced them onto the streets
anywhere the denial of universal
suffrage
the the kidnapping of booksellers the
banning of a political party
the prevention of elected legislative
councillors taking their seats because
they didn't like their politics
it's that constant erosion of freedom
under the one country two systems that's
the system that xi jinping is offering
you
one country two systems um i suggest you
take a look
what's happening here in taiwan in the
roc
the ruling party dpp who claimed that
they protect human rights they protect
democracy
no i have to tell you what's
embarrassing same thing happening here
that's the reason why it's so
embarrassing because our ruling party
is trying to enact martial law here
doing something even worse and there is
one law related to national security
you know that's what they are doing here
our ruling party here in taiwan
of course we criticize the hong kong
government
especially the council try to establish
a law which hong kong residents
disagree and doesn't trust
so that leads to you blame that do you
the chief executive you blame the
carrie lam the chief executive she's
beijing's appointee right
she's the appointee even so-called
elected by
some hong kong representative why is she
still there why is she why hasn't she
resigned well
ask hong kong people ask hong kong
people
it's their democracy it's their system
ask hong kong people let me come back to
the question
and this is the one thing is important
they withdrawal
the law draft right they've suspended it
they've said it
but it's still there they said they
they've said it's dead they said they
withdraw
because they did something wrong they
admit i think
they're just not proceeding with it no
no that's
that's what's happening before now they
say they withdraw
you're satisfied it's over no i'm not
satisfied about that i'm worried about
what's happening here in taiwan
and the one country two systems formula
that xi jinping has offered to taiwan
that's dead no that well that's not
gonna happen
that's not gonna happen then you mean
hong kong is not gonna have
uh different systems from china's system
isn't the last thing i think the system
should exist
because that's the the window shop
for chinese they should show that
improvements of democracy
to the world hong kong system
if they try to violate that it's going
to embarrass them mr cho isn't
a lesson that you should take away from
hong kong is that china doesn't live
up to its promises on democracy isn't
that the lesson
um i think despite talking and wanting
to love china
i don't live up to them i think
we should try to change them we should
try to improve
them you should first say no to them
well how do you know i didn't say no to
them
i've doing that i've been doing that for
so many years
every time i visited china i talked to
them
i say improve your system especially a
democratic system
and they step up their interference with
well they listen
look at the propaganda war that's being
waged against taiwan
a study by the university of gothenburg
in sweden said you're one of china's
major targets for spreading
disinformation
happy about that direct interference
well i think
theoretically the roc so-called taiwan
should be
more opened to outside world
especially western society you're
avoiding
china's disinformation campaign yeah
well china is trying to do that but
other countries
also try to do that too i
think we should take active actions in
solving their problems
we're a very open society but not open
enough to the outside world
take a look how many um english speaking
channels here
take a look at how many how much
international media
existing here in taiwan we're not
exposed
enough to the outside world however
the politicians here try to close the
door
china china close your eyes no wait
china wants to
internationally isolate now we
we emphasize localization so much
instead of internationalization
that's what you don't want to see
first you don't want to admit it no we
want to improve ourselves too
we also want to improve china remember i
want to take
active active process
active approach to china to make china
change
this idea that you can make china change
which frankly is pretty much of a long
shot
why should people vote for your party
next year well
if you're selling fantasies like that
why no we're not selling
fantasies be realistic it's a difficult
competition
why don't you try to realize what dpp
can
do tpp can influence the
election and why don't you take a look
what we are fighting
for we are fighting for true democracy
here
and dpp is ruining democracy here we're
trying to build up a peaceful
relationship
with the china with mainland
we're trying to create a better
society here we're trying to introduce
your systems your values here to taiwan
we're trying so hard to do that if we
want to convince
all people here that kmt can rule this
country perfectly well then we have to
respect the democracy
we have to open our society to the
outside world
we have to be honest to be to our people
but our ruling party is cheating our
people well the bad news for you
is that a plurality of taiwanese 45
don't identify with your party
or the ruling dpp take a look take a
look
you're right you're right they don't
trust the parties here yeah they don't
trust
you and they don't trust them they don't
trust all parties you're not saying
anything that they think is relevant
well i believe that what they're saying
is relevance we realize the facts
already
people don't trust the parties here
people don't trust the politicians here
which is why would they trust you i mean
you you said in the second primary
debate
in the second primary debate you claim
that the number of taiwanese
people below the poverty line was
believed to be around 3.8 million
right which is simply not true
it's simply not true it's true the pure
research organization
says taiwan proportionately contains
fewer people living in poverty
than any other country in asia no let me
tell you
no time money less than two years you
don't
listen to me patiently you know when i
was the mayor
in taipei county they are around one
quarter of the students couldn't afford
their lunch that's one quarter
a few times that proportion to the total
population here in taiwan
i'm telling you the facts i'm not lying
i'm telling you i'm telling you the
facts
that's not the facts that's the fact
i'm telling you the fact why don't you
listen
almost no taiwanese live on less than
1.9 us dollars a day
that's not global poverty like that
that's the definition of
poverty our definition of poverty is
different
oh really my definition of
responsibility to you
right yes relative to that yes that's my
definition
you can criticize my definition you live
inside i can tell you if any students
cannot afford their lunch then
his and his family is living in poverty
that's my definition if it all goes
wrong
here in taiwan and xi jinping loses
patience
and somebody says something they
shouldn't say
and china looks as though it's moving
towards
an invasion would you fight for taiwan
or not where do your ultimate loyalties
lie mr cho we are loyal to our country
the republic of china we're loyal to our
constitution
you would fight in china yes yes yes if
they violated
our constitution to preserve and protect
our people and defend our people i'll
fight against the china
joshi wayne it's good to have you on
conflict son thank you thank you very
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you